all right president Trump's key campaign
promise build that wall takes a major
step forward today the president toured
border wall prototypes during a visit to
San Diego California let's take a look
if you don't have a wall system you're
gonna have we're not gonna have a
country there's a lot of problems in
Mexico they have a lot of problems over
there and they have the cartels and the
cartels we're fighting the cartels and
we're fighting them hard
nobody ever fought them like we fought
and we're looking very much at the wall
with some see-through capability on the
other side and then solid concrete on
top or steel in concrete on top the
round piece that you see up here or you
see more clearly back there the larger
it is the better it is because it's very
hard to get over the top it's really
deterrent from getting over the top who
would think who would think but getting
over the top is easy these are like
professional mountain climbers you're
incredible climbers they can't climb
some of these walls some of them they
can those are the walls we're not using
those are the ones we're not using
alright good idea now the president also
stressed the need for much tighter
border security during a speech at a
Naval Base in San Diego take a look at
this dangerous criminal and terrorist
organizations relentlessly seek to
exploit our immigration system I've just
come from a trip to the border where I
met with our wonderful border agents the
Border Patrol and the ice agents
unbelievable people and reviewed
prototypes of a new physical wall that
will protect our border and protect our
country but that wall will stop so much
and we looked at the different
prototypes and it was fascinating and we
have two or three that really work we
had people trying to scale we've done
them everywhere you know I'm a builder
what I do best is built okay and the
president is blasting the liberal
bastion of California and their Governor
Jerry Brown and of course the very
liberal mayor of Oakland for championing
sanctuary policies that literally put
criminal illegal immigrants before
American citizens and there
safety what's this governor Browns done
a very poor job running California they
have the highest taxes in the United
States the place is totally out of
control
you have sanctuary cities we have
criminals living in the sanctuary cities
and then the mayor of Oakland goes out
and notifies when ice is going in to
pick them up and many of them were
criminals with criminal records and very
dangerous people you would say dangerous
people and I think the governor's doing
a terrible job running the state of
California so the state of California is
literally putting American lives in
danger why because they won't follow the
law cooperate with federal immigration
officials and they are trying to do
their job arrest illegal immigrant
criminals and remove them from the
country now this is a national security
issue
Democrats sadly they're putting politics
and subjecting Americans to unnecessary
dangerous now if one American is the
victim of a crime committed by people
that have no business being in this
country that we know committed other
crimes than Democrats in California well
they will have to own that and what's so
despicable about all of this is that
Democrats continue to lie and
misrepresent the facts when it comes to
illegal immigrant crime here are just a
couple of statistics that the left in
this country don't want you to know
about according to the migration policy
institute look at that about eight
hundred and twenty thousand of 11
million illegal immigrants in America
are convicted criminals the US
Sentencing Commission has also found
illegal immigrants account for 13% of
non immigration related federal
sentencing during the fiscal year 2016
now that's despite the fact that these
illegal immigrants they only make up 3.5
percent of the population it is a
stunning number and that number only
relates to federal sentences it is much
higher when you include convictions by
state and local authorities it is beyond
shameful that the left Democrats Jerry
Brown is Oakland mayor they ignore the
irrefutable data that is out there and
they continue to protect criminal
illegal immigrants liberals have also no
clue about what actually happens at the
border I've been down there we have
shown you I've been at least a dozen
times for
the rio grande of san diego on horseback
on all-terrain vehicles boats look at me
riding a horse I nearly fell off a
helicopter on boats and everything I've
seen the arrests of gang members I've
seen the drug tunnels I've seen the drug
warehouses and everything in between
in 2014 I sat in on this border briefing
about security with then Texas Governor
Rick Perry during a seven-year period
illegal immigrants committed 642
thousand crimes against Texans alone
this is a serious problem
when are we gonna put the safety of the
American people first watch this the
criminal aliens have been responsible
about six hundred forty two thousand
offenses criminal offenses you look up
there on top less sexual assault there's
close to eight thousand victims six
hundred and forty two thousand crimes
two thousand in Texas alone yes over two
hundred thousand individuals their
criminal history reflected there was
daily they were committed over six
hundred forty two thousand crimes that's
the cost of not security that's the
truth about illegal immigrant crime in
this country now the number one it they
don't lie but the left does lie that's
sad and we actually sent a producer
today to talk to protesters that were
gathered outside of the area where
President Trump was viewing these border
wall prototypes today listen to what
these protesters say do we have an
immigration problem in the United States
no the world human beings have wandered
the world since forever since they
crawled out of the swamps
I emigrated forty-something years ago
from one of those cold countries of
trumps I'm a very proud American I'm
hearing exercising my right to disagree
with them I remember when you could just
walk across back and forth to you know
Tijuana and San Diego and I think things
were better than I think Donald Trump is
the most dangerous thing to happen to
our country I hate to say it since World
War two when Hitler really really now
here's another piece of key information
the left desperately wants to keep
secret from you the American people we
like to tell you the truth according to
the Center for Immigration Studies
president Trump's 18 billion dollar
border wall it would actually pay for
itself by reducing illegal immigrant
crime now that means drugs coming across
the border reducing the number of
federal benefits going to illegal
immigrants that don't respect our
sovereignty don't respect our laws now
also tonight we have new bombshell
information about that Clinton bought
and paid for a dossier there's a new
book called Russian roulette now it's
written by liberal journalist Michael
Isikoff and David corn and it's meant to
smear President Trump but instead it is
confirming very key input pieces of
information that we've been telling you
all about the Daily Caller they obtained
a copy of this book they're reporting
that Barack Obama's 2012 campaign now
this is fascinating they actually paid
fusion gps 3 million dollars for op
research on Mitt Romney now the Obama
campaign they were able to hide it get
this by funneling payments to fusion gps
through that law firm perkins cuy that's
the same one hillary used now we reached
out to both President Obama in his
campaign they never got back to us this
is the exact same thing that Hillary
Clinton did except she and the DNC well
they didn't paint three million they
paid over 12 million dollars for a
dossier that use Russian government
sources and lies and misinformation and
propaganda and the Daily Caller
is also reporting on another key piece
of information from the book former
British spy Christopher Steele
openly doubted his own dossier to his
friends and especially one of the
biggest pieces of fake news from the
dossier he had no clue if it was true
was kind of 50/50 if it's true and of
course I'm talking about the completely
ridiculous still never verified
fabricated story about Donald Trump and
hookers at a ritz-carlton in Moscow
urinating in the bed so steel didn't
even think it was true but he included
it anyway and Hillary bought it and then
he gave it to the FBI the FBI didn't do
their job they never verified they never
corroborated it which is not only
protocol but that is part of what the
FISA law tells them to do and then the
FBI used it to secure a FISA warrant
that same thing Christopher Steele
didn't even believe it to spy on an
opposition party candidate in an
election year
and then of course they never told the
FISA judge that the Clinton campaign and
the DNC paid for these unverified
salacious lies and nobody had any clue
at all if it was true Wow and the Daily
Caller is also highlighting how the book
reveals a key source behind this
ritz-carlton claim well turns out that
it's a foreign business in a man named
Sergey Milian now the thing is Sir Jay
is telling the Daily Caller
that the dossier is quote garbage news
well that wasn't hard to figure out why
didn't the FBI do it and finally The
Washington Times reporting on yet
another major revelation from in the
book senior Obama State Department
official Victoria Nuland actually gave
the original approval for an FBI agent
to meet with Christopher Steele about
the fake news dossier and that means
that the Obama administration was
directly involved now we also reached
out to Nuland for comment hoe
spokesperson well got back to us but
never directly addressed our questions
instead he just directed us to old
interviews that she has done on the
topic she thanks very much now this new
revelation is a very key piece of
information why because it started the
entire process of spying on a trump
campaign associate and then ultimately
the Trump campaign so how is it possible
think about this in the United States of
America the FBI never corroborated this
phony dossier
with Russian lies it violated its own
protocols the FISA law itself this is a
massive abuse of power and by the way
the full scope of this is now only
slowly being revealed and it's only
because a few of us are working hard to
get you the truth now there's even more
explosive information that you know is
gonna come out in time so I say to
everybody out there tick-tock stay with
us all right finally tonight ranking
Democratic member on the House
Intelligence rating nothing short of a
propaganda misinformation campaign
against presidents from 2d legitimize
him and hopefully even take him out of
office
and by the way Vladimir Putin would be
proud of all the work Schiff is doing
now remember the Russians main goal what
did we learn was too so political
discord and guess what that is exactly
what congressman Schiff has been doing
in this country non-stop even though he
has now known the entire time no
evidence no proof whatsoever of Russia
Trump collusion take a look at
congressman Schiff
this is his evolution over time on this
issue take a look at this what do you
got Hardwell crit yeah Chris
unfortunately I can't go into the
evidence that's a big you can't reveal
you know I can't reveal that Chris of
course there's one thing to say there's
evidence there's another thing to say we
can prove this or prove it beyond a
reasonable doubt or there's enough
evidence to bring to a grand jury for
purposes of a criminal indictment I
don't think we can say anything
definitively at this point we are still
at the very early stage of the
investigation last March you said you
had more than circumstantial evidence of
treasonous collusion with Russia what
specifically were you referring to and
please be specific because if it's true
I do believe Americans have the right to
know a year later what that is
certainly said that there's ample
evidence of collusion I've never used
the word treason
only Steve Bennett has used that word
but if you look at the the facts that
are already in the public domain they're
pretty damning okay that means he has no
proof great job Megan McCain and
congressman Schiff has proven to be a
national embarrassment deliberately
maliciously misleading the American
people and he's also of course
selectively been leaking like a faucet
to try and damage and discredit
witnesses that appear before the house
Intel committee now immediately after
Republicans reached their findings shift
races over to conspiracy TV MSNBC where
he wants a job desperately to spin a new
narrative because the old narrative
didn't work watch this it became
apparent really from very early on from
almost a year ago with that midnight run
to the White House that the Republicans
on the committee viewed their job as
protecting the president not
investigating what took place
essentially it's the Intelligence
Committee majority saying we just rather
not know if it's gonna be bad news and
that is I think a betrayal of the
promise that was made that we would
follow the facts wherever they lead 14
months you've been investigating this
over at the Intel committee what what
are you and all your Democratic
colleagues potted plants what have you
been doing and if you had the evidence
bring it forward bring it right here on
this show we'll show it to our audience
anyway after that appearance on
conspiracy TV shift is continuing to
play politics with zero evidence that he
can put forward again is this good for
the country take a look last night the
majority on the Intelligence Committee
made the decision to prematurely shut
down the rush investigation the only
authorized investigation in the House of
Representatives into what the Russians
did in the last election what the US
government response was and the issue of
any coordination or collusion with the
Trump campaign that was a terrible
disservice of the country and the
American people and represented a
reneging on the commitment that was made
at the outset of the investigation to
follow the facts wherever they lead
fourteen months no evidence and he wants
to keep going Schiff is just an example
of everything that is wrong in our
modern day political system now he has
no business being in Congress everything
that comes out of his mouth is a lie he
has zero credibility for example just
today Democrats on the house Intel
committee announced that they're going
to continue the Russia investigation on
their own and they're going to try and
counter the findings from Republicans
all you think you would have known in 14
months